Ihr lauft auch immer rum und filmt es!
Ja, machen wir.
Das ist ein bisschen seltsam,
die letzten Leute haben das auch gemacht.
Hi Chad, ich bin Christoph Krachten von Clixoom, der Online-Talkshow.
Mein Rücken schmerzt ein bisschen.
Ist alles ok?
Ich hab einen Schrank im Schlafzimmer aufgebaut und etwas ging schief.
Die Frau wollte den größeren Schrank?
Hier ist Nickelback!
Hallo Leute
Wie ist die Lage?
Großartig! Wir sind in Deutschland,
Wir haben, wie lang haben wir?
Etwa eine Woche? Bis das Album hier rauskommt.
Anderthalb Wochen
Und wir haben gerade herausgefunden, dass das Lied auf Nummer 6 ist.
Wir sind gerade auf Nummer 6, die Single
Das ist sehr aufregend und bedeutet, dass wir
möglicherweise wieder nach Deutschland kommen
und weiter für unsere deutschen Fans spielen können.
Aber warum seid ihr im Moment in Deutschland und nicht in den USA?
Ist Deutschland so wichtig?
Deutschland ist immer wichtig.
Wir waren wahrscheinlich am zweit Häufigsten in Deutschland.
Seit dem ersten Album
Die deutschen Fans waren also ziemlich loyal, deshalb werden wir darauf achten, bei jedem Album ein paarmal herzukommen.
Warum sind die deutschen Fans so treu? Ist Deutschland ein guter Ort für Rockmusik? Oder gibt es hier das beste Publikum?
Deutschland ist bekannt für… nun ja…
Damit du es weisst...
Deutschland hat einen gewissen Ruf
Im Rock-Business ist Deutschland bekannt für seine Liebe für Rock Bands
Als wir anfingen, hieß es:
Ihr müsst nach Deutschland! Ihr müsst nach Deutschland
Er hat deutsche Wurzeln, ich hab auch deutsche Wurzeln.
Demnach musste ich sowieso nach Deutschland, aus anderen Gründen.
Also verbinde ich das Eine mit dem Anderen.
Es ist eine recht langweilige Geschichte,
aber so ist es es halt
Und ihr mögt es hier? Das Land?
Auf jeden Fall, wir kommen nun schon seit 12 Jahren hierher. So um den Dreh. Und es stimmt
wenn du dir in Deutschland eine Fanbase aufgebaut hast, lieben sie dich solange du Platten rausbringst.
So fühlt es sich an.
Und die deutschen Fans sind wirklich gut zu uns.
Darum kommen wir immer wieder zurück,
darum freut es uns jetzt hier zu sein
Wir kommen her, weil es hier viele Deutsche gibt
Wo wir schon bei Fans sind.
Ich habe bemerkt, dass  es manchmal diese "Erste Reihe"
auf Konzerten gibt. Und es ist immer dieselbe Reihe.
Manchmal, durchaus.
Kennt ihr die deutsche "Erste Reihe"?
Die folgt uns über die ganze Welt.
Da sind diese 4, 5 Mädchen die dabei sind, seit wir herkommen.
Und sie stehen immer vor Ryan.
Direkt vor Ryan!
Ein, zwei Auftritte bevor wir nach Deutschland kommen, tauchen sie auf, das wäre dann z.B. in Großbritannien der Fall
Und dann in Deutschland und dann in Österreich, in der Schweiz oder wo wir gerade spielen... und sie sind auch da. Und so weiter
Und normalerweise kommen sie hin und wieder auch zu einigen Auftritten in den USA, dann sieht man sie dort, mit ihren T-Shirts. Du kannst sie jedes Mal erkennen…
Direkt vor Ryan!!!
OK warum??
Das musst du sie fragen.
Du hast sie nicht gefragt?
Nun ja, ich gehe einfach davon aus, weil sie Ryan mögen.
Also dann kennst du sie besser?
Ich denke, es ist viel mehr Platz auf meiner Seite.
Die Leute drängen sich auf Mikes Seite, weil sie ihn mehr mögen als mich. Dadurch ist mehr Platz vor mir und sie, stellen sich deshalb dahin.
Euer neues Album "Here and Now"… Was sind die Unterschiede zu euren früheren Alben Was denkt ihr?
Eine Sache, die wir bei jeder einzelnen Platte versuchen, ist es, die harten Song noch härter zu machen und die eher melodischen noch melodischer.
Wir versuchen unsere Grenzen mit jeder Platte zu erweitern. Und es wird immer schwieriger, denn diese Platte ist zwiegespalten.
Sie deckt alles ab von Metal bis hin zu Balladen und diese Seiten
sind jetzt weiter voneinander entfernt als sie es je waren.
Aber es scheint, als wäre es genau das, was unsere Fans wollen.
Und wir machen das gerne.
Wir gehen nicht jeden Tag ins Studio und sagen: Heute machen wir nur Balladen.
Und wir gehen nicht ins Studio und sagen: Heute machen wir nur Metal
Wir machen es so, wie es uns an dem Tag gerade passt.
Und dabei schwanken wir meist vom dem Einem zum Anderen.
Wenn du die ganze Zeit an einem Metal Stück arbeitest,
wochenlang nur daran,dann ist es abends irgendwann schwierig,
die lauten Gitarren,das Schreien und das Übrige anzuhören.
Und umgekehrt dasselbe.
Du arbeitest 2 Wochen an herzzerreißenden Balladen und irgendwann fühlst du dich ausgepowert und möchtest wieder was Rockiges machen.
Ja, und so in etwa läuft das bei uns.
Wieviele Songs hattet ihr für das Album und wie viele haben es ins Album geschafft?
Das wurden wir oft gefragt. Bei uns sind nur 11 Songs entstanden.
Andere Bands haben 20 bis 30 Songs und schrauben es dann runter, auf die Zahl von Songs, die es letzten Endes auf die Platte schaffen.
Warum arbeiten sie nicht richtig hart an denen, die auf die Platte sollen, anstatt die die Zeit für all die anderen Songs zu verschwenden. Das habe ich nie verstanden.
Aber viele Künstler die ich interviewt habe erzählten mir:
"Ich hatte 40 Songs und nach dem Aufnehmen habe ich mich für 15 oder so entschieden"
Ich meine… wir merken recht schnell ob es sich lohnt einer Idee nachzugehen  und wenn nicht, dann nehmen wir es nicht auf.
Es ist so ein "Ne, das wird nichts. Es ist einfach nicht gut. Es muss besser werden."
Es landet im Müll, oder wenn es eine gute Passage enthält, wird diese vielleicht aufgehoben.
Man kann nie wissen. Wenn du in einem Vers hängst, kommt plötzlich der Vers von vor 3 Jahren wieder hervor und es wird unglaublich gut.
Und ich liebe es, wenn das passiert!
Es kommt nicht oft vor, dass man so zwei Verse verbinden kann, aber auf dieser Platte ist es tatsächlich passiert.
Aber manchmal dauert es sehr lang, bis Songs fertig sind und veröffentlicht werden.
Ich glaube bei "Mull of Kintyre" von Paul McCartney sind von der ersten Idee bis zur  Veröffentlichung 12 Jahre vergangen.
Was ist die längste Zeit, die ihr für einen eurer Songs gebraucht habt?
Das ist eine wirklich gute Frage
Dankeschön. Bitte, merkt euch das!
Ist notiert. Die beste Frage, die uns je gestellt wurde!
Vielen Dank.
Welches ist einer der Längsten?
Ich würde sagen…
Ich denke es ist auf "All the right reasons".
00:16:0.8,00:08:26.0
Wir haben von 2000 an vermutlich 5 oder 6 Jahre lang an "Next Contestant" gesessen
"Next Contestant" haben wir gejammed bevor wir …
Wir haben zu viele Platten aufgenommen
Aber ja, ich denke es ist "Next Contestant" auf "All the right Reasons"
Also 6 Jahre?
6 Jahre, ich denke das ist das Längste, was wir hatten
Und was denkt ihr über euer neues Album? Wird es erfolgreich sein?
Funktioniert deine Kristallkugel? Meine Kristallkugel ist im Laden. Wie sieht's bei dir aus?
Kristallkugel sind im Allgemeinen nicht so mein Fall.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Das ist ne andere Frage, die uns ständig gestellt wird.
Wenn du einen Song schreibst, wie "How you remind me", "Photograph", "Rock Star" oder andere Songs wie diese.
Weißt du, was ein Hit wird? Wir wissen es nicht.
Manchmal wissen wir nichtmal, ob es eine Single wird.
Wir machen sie einfach und wenn sie gut laufen? Großartig! Und wenn nicht?
Dann machen wir einfach so lange weiter Musik, wie die Leute uns zuhören wollen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob uns das so klingen lässt, als hätten wir keinen Plan, von dem was wir tun. Aber wir verdrehen das einfach.
Ein bisschen.
Sozusagen
Es ist Kunst
Aber so ist es. Es gab Zeiten, wo ich mich einfach hingesetzt habe und mir gedacht habe
Dieser Song ist ein toller Song und unsere Fans werden ihn lieben. Genauso, wie wir es genossen haben, ihn zu machen
Und es geht direkt nach oben und direkt nach unten.
Und ich denke… Nein, ich höre einfach auf, zu versuchen mir das einzureden und mache einfach Musik. Und warte ab, was passiert
Ich wünsche euch das Beste für euer neues Album!